the reason why I enjoyed the way they
did this the way they handled it is
because one of my major beats with Xbox
you know how I feel about this song
where it's like
I get setting expectation right I get
being realistic
yeah like the difference between
Nintendo and Antonio everybody else is
that they know how to do the magic
moment when you go oh my God we didn't
see this coming like yo that's crazy
that grown man crying oh my God this is
the Sony kind of dreams oh my God
Nintendo do so y'all smashed it blah
blah that's what Xbox is always lacked
to be
that flare
this is what I'm talking about you sit
there and you said we sit there we
looking at the game I'm like yo that
look that look fire right I look like
Sunset Jet Set Radio and Brutal Legend
had a baby and this character looked
this whole animation when they went for